бути мамою п'ятьох дітей наймолодшому з
яких лише рік
ти Покажи як ти ходиш трохи покажи що ти
вмієш вести перемовини з волонтерами з
усього світу а ось on do
і тільки-но повернутися з робочою
поїздки на херсонщину
з цього зіткане життя Катерини Семенюк
багатодітної мами капеланки і волонтерки
свого наймолодшого сина луку жінка
народила у перший день вторгнення Росії
в Україну Так я народила 24-го це було
Буквально через дві години Після перших
шести років приземлених в нашому місті
яких ми фізично чули і бачили і потім
бункер нас пустили ну ніч була перша
взагалі мене зв'язок не виходило і то
діти Коли ми піднялися та висловили
фотографії просто от в інтернет Все
добре бо дуже багато родичів писало
друзі дуже вдячні всьому світу насправді
зі всього світу люди саме тоді Катерина
вирішила займатися волонтерством і вже
за півтора місяця поїхала допомагати на
деокуповану Київщину ми були всі в шоці
як і вся Україна ми просто почали
волонтерствовати приймати біженців
надавати їм допомогу волонтерську і
також просто морально християнську
допомогу духовну допомогу ми просто
почали їздити на деокупованій території
від Бучі коли відкрилися Там бородянками
приїхали туди одразу майже Уже понад рік
Катерина координує роботу волонтерського
центру в Луцьку щоденно сюди привозять
гуманітарну допомогу з усього світу Так
Тут напевно все їжа знаходиться ми
Стараємося якомога швидше це
якомога швидше віддавати Ну тому що це
ми не віримо в те що на складах має щось
берегтися взагалі нас на складах нічого
не затримуються довше ніж два тижні
просто зразу воно розприділяється чи
бойові зони чи зони окуповані чи тут
переселенцям серед тон харчів одягу та
засобів гігієни є речі які рятують
сміття українським військовим ми надали
запит на турнікети особливі турнікети
турнікети які йдуть безпосередньо в
бригади чи батальйони А І парамедикам це
небучні турнікети це сам Хто знає їх
парами такі мають знати їх Вони
перекривають артерію Мені пояснили так
про медики один турнікет одне життя щоби
знайти і доставити в Україну все
найнеобхідніше без вихідних працює ціла
команда волонтерів рюкзаки для
парамедиків Ми також Зараз маємо запит
від них бачите і це в нас це Чехія нам
надали Ми попросили надихнувшись
волонтерством Катерина вирішила що крім
матеріальної допомоги хоче надавати їй
духовну багатодітна мама приєдналася до
корпусу військових капеланів який є
структурним підрозділом християнської
служби порятунку на базі підрозділу вона
пройшла капеланську підготовкою отримала
сертифікат тепер Катерина може їздити на
фронт не Вступаючи до процесу моя
причина особистості п’ять дітей я не
можу бути підписника і належати повністю
армії присягати тому що в мене є перша
моя Місія це бути матір'ю також є
причина що якщо я вступаю в армію Лави
ЗСУ Я вже не можу волонтерствовать нині
Катерина регулярно їздить на фронт де
духовно опікається як військовими так і
цивільними на нелібуваю по пів дня Часом
буває буває декілька днів Але в мене є
чесно дуже хороша охорона хлопці
броньованих автомобілях я відповідному
Gear снаряді Тобто це бронежилети казки
і проче Тобто я не наражаю себе на таку
небезпеку тому дуже дивно іноді
розуміння до яких
концепції моєї особистої лілії роботи в
людей деяких які негативно ставляться до
того що я мать і їжджу на нуль Але знову
ж таки я ходжу перед Богом і я розумію
чого Мій чоловік підтримує мене і не
тільки Чоловік телефон Катерини не знає
спокою адже пиланство не завершується
після повернення додому жінка
залишається на зв'язку із тими хто цього
потребує щодня так пишуть дзвонять ну з
позиції Дуже часто вони просто пишуть і
ми просто переписуємося дуже часто це
просто помоліться нас дуже сильно криють
артилерії артилерію за ваші молитви Бо
ми дуже часто пишемо ми засмолимося
пам'ятаєте це ну ми є тилом вашими ми
Вас підтримуємо ми вас чекаємо вас
любимо і ви ні про що не піклуєтесь ми
ми все по піклуємося за ваші сім'ї ви
тільки там тримайтеся капеланство і
волонтерство займає чимало часу тож
кожну вільно хвилину Катерина
намагається проводити зі своєю родиною
маленький лука народжений у перший день
повномасштабного вторгнення вже
самостійно ходить Він Лучик ми його
називаємо Лучик він постійно
посміхається дуже спокійно дитя ми
правда не знаємо в кого він пішов Мій
чоловік і ямик або такі легко сказати
інтроверти
і він дуже позитивний він такий
спокійний в нас і часом люди називали
його дитя війни але ми називаємо дитя
миру
для мене це принципово принципово
[музика]